so i was like babe what if we just do
something like go to a city
because we already live in la the
weather's great we can go to a beach and
and i say what if we go somewhere like
like london or paris and she goes
that's a great idea
and i say okay we were going to london
and paris we had it all planned out and
then she was like let's just go to
london and chill i don't want to travel
twice and i go say no more so we went to
london and oops we went in the middle of
the thickest pride pride parade
the thickest dude it was the
bro you think we ho i'm pride is gay
london gets lit london
the game with that accent is probably
really great they go like this hello
they go like this to we hope they go
like this to each other
that is cute
that is cute
it was just gay oh dude and they gay
over there different
outfits yeah all the nipple rings were
out or even taped up because they were
ripped out slaves on them oh yeah bro
there were slaves there were like gays
holding tea oh bro it was the spain is
even worse though by the way well i
don't know but all i know is london
i i couldn't believe my eyes how gay it
was i couldn't believe it i couldn't get
places because it was too gay getting
your dick sucked
stop it a second you have to leave your
dick in the room yeah yeah yeah you have
a dick check
but you got to put it in the safe yeah
yeah
and then you forget the number oh no
and then the guy that comes help me get
it out is the gayest dude
he opens it and there's another even
gayer guy
in there
polishing it
and it's and you're watching it it still
feels good
damn
right wow
full
and the sting and the wing
[Music]
you